in the years I've been associated with
William and Mary I have heard many
graduation speakers heads of state
authors actors successful business
leaders diplomats even a cartoonist or
two and I've had the pleasure of
introducing quite a few of them never
before however have I had to worry about
saying something in the introduction
that would turn on me and be used
against me in the speech John Stewart
now hold on I've got some good stuff
here just give me a chance John Stewart
once observed that the only reason he
would come back to William and Mary was
for a hot Holly I don't know whether
he's raised or lowered his standards but
what is clear that today's speaker is
seriously funny his daily show has been
described as fearless social satire when
the show won the Peabody Award according
to Newsweek magazine it was because
beneath the jokes the show really does
offer seriously intelligent analysis
funny
absolutely but in John's own words the
show is grounded in passion not cynicism
Jon Stewart deftly combines intelligence
and humor he makes us laugh and think
and he's one of our own ladies and
gentlemen it is a pleasure to introduce
you a speaker who proves that there is
something you can do with an
undergraduate degree in psychology from
William and Mary
the host of The Daily Show John Stewart
class of 1984
thank you thank you
Thank You mr. president
I had forgotten how crushing lead all
these ceremonies are thank you
my best to the choir I have to say that
song never grows old for me whenever I
hear that song it reminds me of nothing
I am honored to be here I do have a
confession to make before we get going
that I should explain very quickly when
I am NOT on television this is actually
how I dress I apologize but this is
thank you thank you
there's something very freeing about it
I congratulate the students for being
able to walk even a half a mile in this
non breathable fabric in the
Williamsburg Heat
I am sure the environment that now
exists under your robes are the same
conditions that primordial life began on
this earth I know there were some
parents that were concerned about my
speech here tonight and I want to assure
you that you will not hear any language
that is not common at say a dockworkers
Union meeting or Tourette's convention
or profanity seminar rest assured I am
honored to be here and to receive this
honorary Doctorate when I think back to
the people that have been in this
position before me from Benjamin
Franklin to Queen Noor of Jordan I can't
help but wonder what has happened to
this place seriously it saddens me
as a person I'm honored to get it as an
alumnus I have to say I believe we can
do better and I believe we should but it
has always been a dream of mine to
receive a doctorate and to know that
today without putting in any effort I
will
it's incredibly gratifying thank you
know it's very nice of you I appreciate
it
thank you I'm sure my fellow doctoral
graduates who have spent so long toiling
and academia sinking into debt
sacrificing god knows how many years of
what in truth is a piece of parchment
that has been so devalued by our instant
gratification culture has to been
rendered meaningless we'll join in
congratulating me thank you but today
isn't about how my presence here
devalues this fine institution it is
about you the graduates I'm honored to
be here to congratulate you today
today's the day you enter into the real
world and I should give you a few
pointers on what it is it's actually not
that different from the environment here
the biggest difference is you will now
be paying for things and the real world
is not surrounded by a three-foot brick
wall and the real world is not a
restoration if you see people in the
real world making bricks out of straw
and water those people are not colonial
reenactors they are poor help them
and in the real world there's not as
much candle lighting I don't really know
what it is about this campus and candle
lighting but I wish it would stop we
only have so much wax people let's talk
about the real world for a moment we had
been discussing it earlier and I I
wanted to bring this up to you earlier
about the real world and this is I guess
as good a time as any I don't really
know how to put this so I'll be blunt
we broke it please don't be mad I know
we were supposed to bequeath to the next
generation of world better than the one
we were handed so sorry
I don't know if you've been following
the news lately but it just kind of got
away from us somewhere between the gold
rush of easy internet profits and an
arrogant sense of endless Empire we
heard kind of a pinging noise and then
the damn thing just died on us so I
apologize but here's the good news you
fixed this thing you're the next
Greatest Generation people you do this
and I believe you can you win this war
on terror and Tom Brokaw's kissing your
ass from here to Tikrit let me tell you
and even if you don't you're not going
to have much trouble surpassing my
generation if you end up getting your
picture taken next to a naked guy pile
of enemy prisoners and don't give the
thumbs-up
you've outdid us we declared war on
terror we declared war on terror it's
not even a noun so good luck
after we defeated I'm sure we'll take on
that bastard unwi but obviously that's
the world what about your lives what
piece of wisdom can i impart to you
about my journey that will somehow ease
your transition from college back to
your parents basement
I know some of you are nostalgic today
filled with excitement and perhaps
uncertainty of what the future holds
I know six of you are trying to figure
out how to make a bong out of your caps
believe you are members of psy you
and that did work thank you for the
reference so I thought I'd talk a little
bit about my experience here at William
and Mary it was very long ago and if you
had been to William and Mary while I was
here and found out that I would be the
commencement speaker 20 years later you
would be somewhat surprised and probably
somewhat angry I came to William and
Mary because as a Jewish person I wanted
to explore the rich tapestry of Judaica
that is southern Virginia
imagine my surprise when I realized the
tribe was not what I thought it meant in
1980 I was 17 years old when I moved to
Williamsburg my Hall was in the basement
of Yates which combined the cheerfulness
of a bomb shelter with the prison like
comfort of the group shower as a
freshman I was quite a catch
less than five feet tall yet my head is
the same size it is now didn't even
really look like a head it looked more
like a container for a head I looked
like a peanuts character peanuts
characters had terrible acne but what I
lacked in looks I made up for with the
repugnant personality in 1981 I lost my
virginity only to gain it back again on
appeal in 1983
you could say that my one saving grace
was academics where I excelled but I did
not and yet now I live in the rarefied
air of celebrity of mega stardom my life
a series of anonymous Hollywood orgies
and Kabbalah Center brunches with the
cast of friends at least that's what my
handlers tell me I'm actually too
valuable to live my own life and spend
most of my days in a vegetable crisper
to remain fake news anchor fresh so I
know that the decisions that I made
after college worked out but at the time
I didn't know that they would see
College is not necessarily predictive of
your future success and it's the kind of
thing where the path that I chose
obviously wouldn't work for you for one
you're not very funny so how do you know
what is the right path to choose to get
the result that you desire and the
honest answer is this you won't and
accepting that greatly eases the anxiety
of your life experience I was not
exceptional here and I'm not now I was
mediocre here and I'm not saying aim low
not everybody can wander round and in
alcoholic haze and then at 40 just you
know decide to be president you've got
to really work hard
to try to
I was actually referring to my father
when I left William and Mary I was
shell-shocked
because when you're in college it's very
clear what you have to do to succeed and
I imagine here everybody knows exactly
the number of credits that they needed
to graduate where they had to buckle
down which introductory psychology class
would Pat out the schedule you knew what
you had to do to get to this college and
to graduate from it but the unfortunate
yet truly exciting thing about your life
is there is no core curriculum the
entire place is an elective the paths
are infinite and the results uncertain
and it can be maddening to those that go
here especially here because your
strength has always been achievement so
if there's any real advice I can give
you it's this college is something you
complete life is something you
experience so don't worry about your
grade or the results or success success
is defined in myriad ways and you will
find it and people will no longer be
grading you but it will come from your
own internal sense of decency which I
imagine after going through the program
here is quite strong love what you do
although I'm sure downloading illegal
files but that no that's a different
story love what you do get good at it
confidence is a rare commodity in this
day and age and let the chips fall where
they may and the last thing I want to
address is the idea that somehow this
new generation is not as prepared for
the sacrifice and the tenacity that will
be needed in the difficult times ahead I
have not found this generation to be
cynical or apathetic or selfish they are
as strong and as decent as any people
that I have met and I will say this on
my way down here I stopped at Bethesda
Naval and when you talk to the young
kids that are there that have just been
back from Iraq and Afghanistan you don't
have to worry about the future that you
hear from so many that are not a part of
this generation but judging it from
above and the other thing
that I will say is when I spoke earlier
about the world being broke I was
somewhat being facetious because every
generation has their challenge and
things change rapidly and life gets
better in an instant I was in New York
on 9/11 when the towers came down I
lived 14 blocks from the Twin Towers and
when they came down I thought that the
world had ended and I remember walking
around in a daze for weeks and Mayor
Giuliani had said to the city you've got
to get back to normal we've got to show
that things can change and get back to
what they were and one day I was coming
out of my building and on my stoop was a
man who was crouched over and he
appeared to be in deep thought and as I
got closer to him I realized he was
playing with himself
and that's when I thought you know what
we're gonna be okay thank you
congratulations I honor you
good night
thank you
Thank You Jon Stewart I doubt any of us
have ever heard anything like that
before it commencement it's wonderful
now we will proceed to awarding honorary
degrees
madam rector if you will please join me
it is my privilege to present Jon
Stewart do you have to come back up here
he just asked whether he's getting
bumped down to a masters I said no John
Stewart comedian commentator graduate of
the College of William and Mary and
highly respected purveyor of counterfeit
news your insight has had a very real
and most welcome effect on this nation's
civic discourse you're literate humane
and hilarious criticism reflects a
passion for our country's potential and
reminds us when this potential goes
unfulfilled at the college you pursued a
major in psychology and played wing for
the William Murray soccer team coach Al
Albert who has remained a friend that
mentor was among those who helped you
distinguish between what is important
and what pretends to be this gift of
discernment along with material gain
from jobs as a bartender carpenter
mosquito sorter and puppeteer inspired
your remarkably quick rise to the top of
the nation's comedy circuit your
reputation for connecting with any
audience grew during the early 1990s
when more and more television and film
projects sought the services of an
intelligent and charismatic comedian
it was MTV's the Jon Stewart Show that
best prepared you to remake Comedy
Central's The Daily Show as its host and
executive producer it soon became the
Daily Show with Jon Stewart and then as
its promotional advertisements say
humbly the most important television
show ever its importance has been
recognized with three Emmys a number of
Critics Choice Awards a George Foster
Peabody Award and the nearly uniform
praise of the journalists and
politicians whom you hold accountable
every evening never forgetting that as
Shakespeare wrote in the comedy of
errors every why have to wear four you
highlighted the absurdities in politics
and the media 2/10 that dominate the
modern carnival of American culture
behind the Daily Show's desk you are
indignant but not malicious
well-informed but not patronizing
uninhibited but not unhinged
a common sense everyman with an uncommon
ly quick wit John Stewart in recognition
of your efforts to elevate and focus our
country's conversation your alma mater
is proud to honor you by virtue of the
authority vested in me by the Board of
Visitors and the ancient Royal Charter
the College of William and Mary I hereby
confer upon you the degree of Doctor of
Arts honoris causa